Nashville, 'Music City',
where aspiring artists stake
their claim for stardom.
But is that American
dream here waking up
to a new reality of corporate
investment, sky-high property
taxes, and a tourist boom?
And can the musicians
who once hoped
to turn their struggle
into success even
afford to live here anymore?
Nashville has always been an
affordable place for musicians
to get their start.
And I worry that we're
losing that affordability.
And I find myself wondering
how many Garth Brooks out there
are not going to
make it and are not
going to come out and
grace us with their music
because they couldn't come
here in the first place,
because they couldn't
afford to be here.
I remember when I
first moved here,
and people would spend $300 to
crash on their friend's couch
or room.
And now we're talking $2,000,
$3,000, $4,000 a month to live.
Many locals describe
the city's evolution
as a kind of Las Vegasication,
a shift towards spectacle,
commercialisation,
and mass entertainment
at the expense of authenticity.
There were always tourists
going to the honky-tonks
on Lower Broad.
Tootsie's was one
of the most famous.
We'd go see bands that
record labels wanted to sign.
But you could still get in.
You could still
get a beer for $2.
And then I would say, about 10
years ago, it just exploded,
where every major artist has
their own honky-tonk and bar.
You can be down there
on a Thursday morning,
and there's a line.
They want you to come
in, get a bucket of beer,
drink it, and get out.
The drinking came along with the
music, but it was music first.
Now there's more
of a crowd that's
here to party and raise hell.
It's a conscious decision of
what type of tourism you get.
Authenticity sells,
and it's long-term.
Flashy lights, that's temporary.
The culture here used to
be grassroots, accessible,
distinctly local.
But that identity is evolving.
The show Nashville, that became
not only nationally popular
but internationally
popular, drove this kind
of new wave of tourism.
So you have the
corporate travel,
the convention travel that was
fuelled by the new convention
centre.
And then you have
the individual travel
and us shifting to be called
the bachelorette capital
of the world.
You've got to have
the tourist dollars.
But there's a way to
take in tourism money
and then reinvest
it in the community.
We had about $11bn in
visitor spending in 2024.
It equates to about $3,600
of revenue that, otherwise,
the citizens of Nashville would
have to cover in state and local
taxes.
So it really does have a
positive impact on households.
It helps us to fund the services
that our community desperately
needs.
Many long-term
residents are already
struggling to keep up with
rising costs in Trump's America.
The question now is whether
Nashville's identity is still
rooted in community
or in capitalism.
Tax is a key issue.
Republicans say
Tennessee's low-tax regime
has been a big draw
for big companies
like Amazon, Oracle,
and Starbucks.
Residents might not
have to pay income tax,
but Democrats say
this has pushed
revenue raising
into other areas,
like sales taxes
and property taxes.
And that has left smaller
companies exposed.
That's becoming
a real issue here
in Nashville, Davidson
County, with the assessments
that are skyrocketing.
We've got businesses,
constituents that their tax
bill is quadrupling.
One business downtown,
Acme Feed and Seed,
right there on First
Avenue and Broadway,
their tax bill went from
$129,000 to over $600,000 in one
year.
As property valuations
rise, so do property taxes.
And some lease agreements mean
it's the tenants rather than
the owners who have to pay up.
For business, you
need certainty.
You've got to be able to rely
on the people working for you.
You need to be able to have a
business plan and work the plan.
You can't, overnight,
increase your taxes by 400%.
Our tax code discriminates
against small businesses.
It's really tough in this
environment right now.
And a lot of that
hostility has been
channelled into condemning the
mayor for increasing property
taxes.
The period from
2021 to 2025 just
saw a leap in property
values countywide,
we haven't seen
since I can recall.
That's a challenge.
And it's the only
way we can operate
a city in the state of
Tennessee, in the United States,
is that property
taxes are the largest
portion of the revenue that
we have to keep our parks
and libraries open, to fund our
schools, to fund our police.
The construction of the
new football stadium
has also raised tensions.
They're building a new stadium
over there, a covered dome
stadium.
It's subsidised by the city.
Oracle's building a
big campus over there.
It's subsidised by the city.
Amazon built two towers
that are subsidised...
By the city.
I know there's been
tension around the stadium
and the push-and-pull of
tourism versus locals.
And it's something we see play
out in a number of places.
There's this tourist versus
local that starts to happen.
And I want to see it as a
both/and not an either/or.
We can be investing in our
schools and our teachers
and our affordability but
also building state-of-the-art
buildings that draw people in
to help pay some of those bills.
Long-term residents are
feeling the squeeze.
Housing costs have doubled since
2018, largely driven by luxury,
high-density development
that is transforming historic
working-class neighbourhoods.
Several of our artists,
in the past five years,
have moved back
to their hometowns
just because they couldn't
afford to live here anymore.
People are coming to Tennessee
because of the low tax,
the low regulation.
There's no state income tax.
We are a low tax-state for
multinational corporations
and the rich.
And we are a high-tax
state for working families.
Our tax code inevitably allows
multinational corporations,
like FedEx, Amazon, and
Google, to muscle their way out
of paying taxes, whereas small
business owners, including Acme,
they are paying a
higher effective tax
rate than the largest
companies in this country.
They're driving people out while
trying to recruit people left
and right to be in
the downtown area.
The policies they're putting
in place are pushing them out.
Things that can be done
by a city and community
- an example that we have
actually done here in Nashville
- is creating housing that
provides subsidised housing
for artists and musicians.
The challenge now is not just
sustaining economic momentum
but making sure the songwriters,
performers, and creatives
who define Nashville's
global brand can continue
to live, work, and thrive in the
city they helped put on the map.
You can't take these
things for granted.
That's what we've
learned over the years,
is you can't just assume that
'Music City' brand will be
protected when it's becoming
harder and harder for musicians
and artists to live here.
And it's really...
it is bigger than just the city.
It's really a state,
council, and city problem.
And they have to get together to
create a grander vision of where
we're trying to go and all work
together to execute that vision.
The mayor can't
do it on his own.
The state can't do
it on their own.
Council can't do
And there's just been a total
lack of communication or vision
in how we make sure
to protect this.
From honky-tonks to high-rises,
Nashville's evolution
tells a story, of
growth, opportunity,
and unintended consequences.
As the city continues to
expand, the challenge is clear,
to preserve its
cultural identity
and ensure that
prosperity is shared,
because in Nashville, music
isn't just an industry,
it's the foundation
of everything.